bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que là est ce que la traduction
conson oui
je sais en syrie je suis très heureuse
de vous voir thierry bien sûr que ça
marche
ok c'est bon laurent huneault laurent
maria carey
j'ai entendu comme armani people are you
come combien de gens sont avec vous ici
ce soir maria je ne sais pas 10 d'où ce
qu'il s'est passé normes plus que ce
dont elle a besoin et oui j'avais
traduit qui avait traduit alors les
speaks english perf à clé yassine ben
alors
maillard bonsoir zeroual comme vous
sortez ça va pas être possible
alors marié à vous sortez votre premier
album depuis 2002 depuis charm bracelet
tu sais donc le grand come back de
mariah carey avec un album qui s'appelle
vie humaine c'est personnel mimi
l'émancipation de mini voilà alors min
en fête c'est votre surnom qui jusque là
étaient réservées à uniquement à des
gens très proches de voir ce qu'est ce
que j'ai choisi le nom de mon album tout
le monde sait maintenant mais ni mon
surnom mais le fait d'appeler votre
album l'émancipation de mimi est ce que
ce n'est pas une façon de de baisser un
peu votre garde et de vous rapprocher de
vos fans maria je pense que oui elle
pense que j'ai pas dit une connerie tu
elle me fait un sourire
il y aura plein de mystères et un talent
c'est un android
alors votre père était un faux américain
d'origine vénézuélienne
ce qui fait marié vous avez une enfance
assez difficile parce qu'à l'époque les
mariages mixtes étaient pas très bien
accepté dans la dans la société
américaine
je crois que c'est encore difficile à
gérer le mariage unique ce taux aux
etats unis c'est encore quelque chose
qui n'est pas facile surtout les enfants
alors votre maire a été rejetée par sa
propre famille parce qu'elle avait
épousé un un noir et le mariage était
très très difficile vos parents se sont
séparés ils ont divorcé quand vous aviez
trois ans et vous vous avez eu beaucoup
de mal à vivre votre votre identité
métisse non c'est pas ton identité c'est
la situation qui était difficile tant
que vous savez qui vous êtes en tant que
personne et bien on s'en sort c'est la
musique qui m'a permis d'en sortir donc
c'est une très bonne chose c'est c'est
un talon vous disiez que vous étiez trop
blanche pour être noir est trop noir
pour être blanche et vous avez du mal à
vous situer c'est vrai enfin c'est comme
ça que les gens me perçoivent dans une
enfance assez difficile finalement parce
que confrontées avec le le racisme la
voiture de vos parents a été détruite
devant chez vous votre chien a été
empoisonné et le pire encore c'était à
l'école c'est à dire que vous souffriez
beaucoup du racisme quotidiennement à
l'école c'est vrai vous savez j'ai
d'espoir j'espère que les gens aient
voulu que les gens changent parce que
c'est vraiment qu'on est obsédé par
l'apparence des gens qu'on ne se
préoccupe pas ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur et c'est ça qui compte
vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui ça serait
plus facile pour une petite mariah carey
à l'école j'ai beaucoup d'amis qui ont
des enfants métis et qui finalement
vivre les mêmes choses que moi j'ai vécu
c'est plus facile aujourd'hui mais ce
n'est pas 100% arrangé j'écris
actuellement un livre pour enfants pour
les enfants apprennent mixte un espèce
de vade mecum et je pense que ça les
attire
oui parce que vous c'était très dur un
jour vous amener une copine à la maison
elle voit votre père elle n'a jamais vu
un noir de sa vie et elle se met à
pleurer en voyant votre père il a fallu
que sa mère la ramène chez elle parce
que elle était vraiment victime d'une
d'une crise d'hystérie et vous avez
beaucoup souffert aussi cessé d
histoires terribles que vous avez vécu
un jour à l'école on vous demande de
dessiner votre famille et pour dessiner
votre père vous prenez un crayon noir et
à ce moment là tout le monde comprend
que votre père et noir et tout le monde
s'éloigne de vous je pensais pas qu'en
amérique il ya quelques années donc
quand vous étiez enfant il y avait
encore autant de racisme dans la vie
quotidienne je pensais quand il m'avait
- c'était quelque chose qui n'était pas
forcément très présent très ouvert où on
remarquait de petites choses et il
fallait les gérer à l'intérieur survivre
garder ça pour soi gérer les situations
mais on a tous nos difficultés je ne
vais pas dire la fin c'était moi moi
j'ai eu ces problèmes tout le monde a
des problèmes c'est le monde souffrent
du racisme d'une manière ou d'une autre
c'est juste que quand on a un parent
blanc et un parrain noir et bien on ne
comprend pas ni à part andy dos ne
comprend vraiment la situation de
l'enfant voilà alors votre mère était
chanteuse d'opéra et professeur de chant
et et c'est elle qui a découvert en fait
votre votre talent votre don pour paula
pour la chanson quand vous étiez petit
vous y mettiez ses vocalises comme un
magnétophone quoi parfois vous corrigiez
même ces fausses notes c'est vrai ça une
fois je les corrige une fois c'est ce
qu'elle a raconté
ah ah ah ah ok mais ça me rappelle le
nex nex wikleaks la semaine prochaine
bon show quand vous avez votre votre
diplôme de change est parti de la maison
pour aller tenter votre chance et à new
york c'est ça oui en gros oui et alors
là vous faites des petits boulots
pendant la journée
vous êtes serveuse et vestiaire vous
êtes hôtesses et la nuit vous fait des
maquettes des maquettes de chansons
j'ai jusqu'au jour où quelqu'un donne
une de vos maquettes à tommy mottola qui
à l'époque était le grand patron de sony
qui a donné la maquette à tony mottola
c'était pas une grande chanteuse acr
je suis un peu perdue parce que vous
vous me posez des questions sérieuses et
lui me pends de fruits légumes alors je
ne saurais le dire est ce que montre
intéressé l'émancipation des mini qu'est
ce qu'on fait non les mois brenda questa
a donné la démo riehl à tony mottola qui
lui a trouvé ça formidable qui vous a
signé un contrat c'est un jeu tant conte
de fées en fait j'avais un accord avec
les warner bros 2 qui qui était sur le
point d'être signé et je n'ai presque
pas été à la fête à laquelle brenda a
donné la démo et finalement j'y suis
allé et tout s'est bien passé et ça m'a
permis finalement d'écrire mes propres
chansons
j'avais plus d'un label qui
s'intéressait à moi donc je pouvais dire
aux gens non vous pouvez pas me forcer à
faire ce que je ne veux pas faire donc
[Applaudissements]
quoi
j'ai j'ai dit 140 millions d'albums
vendus il a un autre qui file à 130
millions cheryl faut pas croire tout ce
qu'on dit ça c'est vous it's you with
you ça c'est bon 27 mar 70 c'est bon ça
des six mais c'est moi j'étais petit
mais ce point
en vérité des chiffres
donc à 24 ans d'épouser tony mottola
3000 personnes au mariage et qu'est ce
qui se passe après pourquoi dans ce
couvent ou sombrer dans la dépression
vous dit
les limites étaient dépassées c'était le
gouffre pourquoi parce que c'était une
relation très difficile d'être avec
quelqu'un qui avait le double méninges
qui était le directeur de mirabel dont
le meilleur ami et l'avocat et dans tous
les arts sont des gens qui travaillent
pour lui c'est pas très drôle c'est
c'était plutôt terne et maussade
est-ce qu'à l'époque on a dit que vous
aviez des problèmes de drogue c'est vrai
ça aurait été plutôt bien d'avoir de la
drogue pour supporter tout ça vous avez
pensé à vous suicider à l'époque dont
c'est parce que vous savez c'était quand
même une situation dans laquelle j'étais
très malheureuse et c'est pour ça que je
suis parti que j'ai quitté cette
situation parce qu'elle ne me convenait
pas après vous trouvé l'énergie de vous
en sortirez vous vous réfugiez chercher
votre mère ce qui est très symbolique
d'ailleurs vous vous vous réfugiez dans
la maison que vous aviez offert à votre
mère avec votre premier katché oui c'est
vrai
et là quand vous arrivez chez votre mère
vous vous effondrez sur le carrelage de
la cuisine elle appelle une ambulance et
on vous amène l'hôpital pendant quelque
temps dans quelques temps j'étais
vraiment à bout quoi si j'étais à bout
et quand vous ai trouvé l'énergie de
revenir après vous savez j'avais besoin
de repos et aujourd'hui je me dis que
finalement c'était une bonne chose il
faut savoir quand s'arrêter quand se
reposer et et si je n'avais pas craqué
je ne sais pas ce qui aurait pu se
produire
je ne sais pas quel aurait été le
résultat donc quelque part ça a été une
bonne chose un mal pour un bien
je pense qu'aujourd'hui je produis de
meilleur album de ma carrière et
finalement tout ce qu'on traverse et
qu'on survit vous rend plus fort
et c'est mon objectif moi j'essaye de de
nourrir ma musique de tout ce que j'ai
vécu
et d'essayer de d'en sortir une
meilleure personne ni personne plus
forte et sentimentalement comment ça va
alors maria maintenant sentimentalement
les gens viennent pas vers moi comme si
j'étais quelqu'un d'autre parce qu'il y
à l'égard du corps et biens c'est
difficile d'entrer en contact avec moi
et et je suis toujours entouré d'une
foule mais ça fait partie comme mode
c'est comme ça vous vous pensez que vous
pensez que vous fait peur aux hommes un
peu maria j'espère que non mais
peut-être que oui peut-être que oui vous
allez rester longtemps à paris offre
encore une demi heure
et puis je veux pas elle a le député
européenne se finir plan j'aime venir
ici
oui j'ai acquis ma tasse après on va en
allemagne ce soir vous partez ce soir là
bas sinon tu as le 131 matin ils
arrivent à porte de la chapelle et là il
ya des bus pour l'allemagne qui rit
c'est jamais rappelé m
secret
but c'est un but pour l'allemagne
ça m'est égal comment j'y arrive je sens
que je sais s'il le faut je prendrai les
830 42 la chatte ssp crise ça se passe
est ce que vous êtes une diva je suppose
on arrête à une faute était question
donc je dois être une diva on va
vérifier interview diva alors on va voir
mariah carey si vous êtes une vie va
est-ce que vous avez déjà demandé que
votre chambre d'hôtel soit tapissé de
fleurs non est-ce que vous avez déjà
fait voyager votre chien en business
class entre new york et los angeles pour
lui faire un bisou
il est trop grand je dois l'emmener dans
un avion privé
donc ce n'est pas vraiment d'histoire et
et mon chien s'appelle jack jack est
très célèbre
est-ce que vous avez déjà exigé qu on
ouvre un magasin spécialement pour vous
non mais ce qui se passe c'est qu'on
rentre dans un magasin et les gens
savent que je vais dépenser de l'argent
et donc ça sortir tout le monde à leur
demande pas de le faire et un généreux
je ne suis pas là très tôt et j'arrive
un petit peu en fin de journée donc ils
sont sur le point de fermer mais s'ils
savent que je vais dépenser des sous ils
restent ouverts c'est du bon sens
commercial
est-ce que vous avez déjà exigé qu'un de
vos fans se brosse les dents avant de
vous embrasser non
est-ce que vous avez déjà exigé qu'on
parce que vos disques dans une boîte de
nuit où vous allez danser
j'aime entendre ce que font d'autres
gens en discothèque
est-ce que vous avez déjà réserver
toutes les tables d'un restaurant pour
pouvoir dîner tranquillement
mais peut-être est-ce que vous avez déjà
exigé d'avoir une piscine dans votre
loge c'est excellent pour les cheveux et
le maquillage savez est-ce que vous avez
déjà exigé de l'eau minérale pour vous
laver les cheveux
non non est-ce que vous avez exigé que
votre entourage voit votre film glitter
gallois n'ont pas question sa présence
toile il ya une tradition dans cette
émission c'est que tous les invités
tirer une carte mes livres
[Musique]
carte confession vous devez qu'on fait
c'est quelque chose que vous avez sur le
coeur
j'ai vraiment je me pose des questions
polies là j'ai regardé des cassettes du
show et c'est pour ça que je suis venu
ce soir
donc en fait il m'impressionne beaucoup
une il me rend très nerveux
merci merci beaucoup tube en commun
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus